[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم محمد مزيماز
لنستعرض معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
بايجاز وفي نشرت هنا
ابل تكشف عن نظرته
عمليه على الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه
ميسي الى امريكا وبنزيما الى السعوديه
لنبدا مع شركه ابل واقتحامها عالم
الميتافيرس الذي تهيمن عليه
سيكونون قادرين على تحديد المحتوى باعينهم
مع استخدام نظام كاميرا وميكروفون ثلاثي
الابعاد لالتقاط مقاطع مصوره وصور يمكن
عرضها في شكل ثلاثي الابعاد لاحقا لن اجد
افضل من الزميل اياد حميده مقدم برنامج
حياه الذكيه ليعطينا تفاصيل اكثر عن هذه
النظاره يا مرحبا اياد اهلا بك محمد
بهذه الجدليه منذ فتره طويله هل تعتقد
بانها بالفعل غامرت بطرح هذه النظاره
ستغامر ان قلنا ان النظاره الجديده ستكون
بديل عن هاتف او لهاتف ايفون حصان الرابح
في سوق ولكنها اكدت ان هذا المنتج الجديد
هو عباره عن منتج قائم بذاته استخدامه
بشكل مستقل بعيدا عن الايفون والحواسيب
ماك مع امكانيه ربط هذا المنتج بالحواسيب
والايفون طبعا لتقديم تجربه
مثيره من حيث الاستخدامات اداء المهام
الانتاجيه الترفيه وما الى ذلك ولكن
الوحيد او من سيقرر فشل هذه النظاره من
عدمه هو الجمهور بالمقام الاول وايضا
المطورون الذين ستطرح لهم نظاره بدايه
العام المقبل
لتطوير تطبيقات خاصه بهذه النظاره
بالتاكيد انا شخصيا متحمس لتجربه هذه
النظاره متاعًا انا كذلك ولكن لن ادفع
السعر غالي هو احد التحديات الكبرى 3500
دولار سعر باهض واعتقد ان ابل يجب ان تعيد
النظر في هذه النقطه شكرا
الى موضوع اخر ضمن ايجانا الاسبوع هجوم
غير مسبوق منذ 33 عاما على الحدود المصريه
اذ اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه من
افراده برصاص جندي مصري عند معبر العوجه
التحقيقات الاوليه الاسرائيليه اظهرت ان
منفذ العمليه محمد صلاح خطط لمسار تسلله
وقطع مسافه طويله قبل ان يجتاز الحدود
ويستهدف الجنود ثم يقتل اسرائيل اعلنت
تسليم جثمان الجندي الى مصر وقلت انها
تجري تحقيقا مشتركا مع القاهره فيما وصفته
باختراق امني كبير نشاط التواصل شهاده
التفاعلات النواسعه بعد كشف هويه الجندي
المصري نرصر لكم بعضا من تعليقاتكم ادهم
ابو سلميه يقول جندي مصري من خير اجناد
الارض اسمه شهيد محمد صلاح اخبرنا بفعله
ان الطريقه لفلسطين مفتوحه لمن قرر
المسيره لها كما اخبر الصهاينه ان التطبيع
الشعبيه لم ولن يكون اما محمد عزمي فقال
في تغريده كلما انحرفت البوصله عن القدس
وفقدنا الامل تاتينا مصر بخيره ابناءها
لتحيي فينا العروبه وتقول لنا لستم وحدكم
الله يرحمك يا ابو صلاح مثل ما يقول محمد
وفي جنوب لبنان توتر اخر فقد شهدت منطقه
وكفر شوبا مواجهات بين مواطنين اللبنانيين
والجيش الاسرائيلي على خلفيه تجريفه اراضي
زراعيه تابعه لهم وهو ما دفع قوات الطوارئ
الدوليه للتدخل من اجل تخفيف هذا التوتر
كما انتشر مقطع فيديو لمزارع لبناني يتصدى
بجسده بجرافات اسرائيليه وقد حصد ملايين
المشاهدات ندعوكم لمتابعه جزء من ذلك
المقطع
[موسيقى]
كارثه غير مسبوقه حرائق في كندا تاتي على
ملايين الهكتارات من الغابات وتدفع الاف
السكان لنزوح من مناطقهم الدخان الناجم عن
هذه الحرائق تسبب بتدهور جوده الهواء في
الولايات المتحده وهو ما دفع البيت الابيض
الى دعوه الذين يعانون من مشاكل صحيه
لاتخاذ الاحتياطات المناسبه للوقايه من
تلوث الهواء كما رصد دخان على بعد الاف
الكيلومترات في النرويج الى تطورات حربيه
اوكرانيا فقد شهدت منطقه خرسون تفجير سد
كخوفكا اكبر سدود البلاد ومع تبادل
الاتهامات بين كييف وموسكو بشان تفجير
السد تواصل السلطات الاوكرانيه عمليات
اجراء السكان من مدينه خرسون بعد ان غمرت
مياه الفيضانات الاف المنازل اما في مناطق
السيطره الروسيه فقد فرضت السلطات حاله
الطوارئ ولكن ما تداعيات تفجير السد على
الامن العلمي ينضم الي ممثل الجزيره حسان
مسعود
مرحبا حسان برنامج الاغذيه العالميه حذر
من تفاقم ازمه الجوع عالميا بعد تفجير
السد ما هي اسنادها المطروحه نعم محمد
تفجير سد كخوفك في خرسوني يؤثر بشكل مباشر
على ازمه الغذاء العالميه نظرا لان منطقه
خرسون هي من اكثر المناطق التي تحتوي على
اراضي زراعيه تفجير هذا السد ادى الى غمر
عشره الاف هكتار على الاقل من الاراضي
الزراعيه الا ان ايضا مساحات كبيره ستتاثر
بفعل انخفاض القدره على ري هذه المناطق
التقديرات الرسميه الاوكرانيه هي 1.5
مليون هكتار من الاراضي الزراعيه ستتاثر
بشكل غير مباشر ايضا وكذلك ايضا عدم وجود
مياه صالحه للريف تلك المنطقه لفتره طويله
من المرتقب ايضا ان تؤثر هذه الازمه وهذه
الحادثه على الاراضي الزراعيه لخمس سنوات
قادمه شكرا
بالاخبار الرياضيه
لهذا الاسبوع فبعد الجدل الذي اثير بشان
عوده ليونيل ميسي الى برشلونه او انتقاله
الى الدوري السعودي اعلن النجم الارجنتيني
انضمامه الى نادي انتر ميامي الامريكي
ليلعب لاول مره خلال مسيرته خارج حدود
اوروبا في سياق اخر اعلنت اتحاد ضد
السعوديه
كريم بنزيما حتى عام 2006
وقدمه الى الجماهير في حفل كبير بملعب
الجوهره المشعه بجانبي هنا حيث نسجل ايجاز
الاسبوعيه زميلنا حمزه الراضي مضيع نشر
الرياضيه في الجزيره مرحبا حمزه اهلا بك
يا محمد تحيه لك يلا يحييك هل انضمام
رونالدو بنزيما
الى دورتمام جماهير العالمي بالدوري
السعودي
ما حدث مع بنزيما بالنسبه لاتحاد جده قبل
ايام هو استمرار للحاله التي صنعها
كريستيانو رونالدو واحد من افضل اللاعبين
في العالم ليس فقط من الناحيه الكرويه لكن
من الناحيه الجماهيريه على مستوى الدوري
السعودي من الناحيه التسويقيه شاهدنا كيف
ارتفعت اعداد المتابعين في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لهذه الانديه التي جلبت هؤلاء
النجوم وبالتالي فان انعكاس هذا على
الدوري السعودي بشكل عام سيكون انعكاسا
ايجابيا وسيجعل منهم دوريا متابعا ليس فقط
في المنطقه ولكن على مستوى العالم وهو في
اطار الرؤيه طبعا السعوديه لان يكون من
بين افضل 10 دوريات في العالم فهونك حديث
عن لاعبين اخرين سينظمون ربما في ايام
البشر المقبله ربما شكرا جزيلا لك حمزه
شكرا لك
ادعوهم مع بعض الى اللقاء شكرا
[موسيقى]